The war is over.
You know, most of us have given up most of our privacy already.
If you are giving all of your financial disclosures online,...
...your credit card, your social security and so forth,...
...I think the way we protect those things can afford us the ability to protect our medical records as well.
It's moving in this direction.
In fact, one would say there is almost a moral obligation for people...
...to begin to disclose at least a portion of their medical records online...
...because it's only through that disclosure on a large scale,...
...whether it's your, not necessarily your name and identity, but at least your phenotypical data and your genomic data...
...will allow us to create a whole revolution in personalized preventative medicine...
...which I think is extraordinarily important for the next few decades.
We are testing what it is like to lose privacy now.
The loss of privacy inherent in these technologies...
...is a precursor to an almost biological or extrasensory loss of privacy that will come as the species evolves.
Shame that could be used to control us will no longer be able to control us...
...because we'll find out that everybody masturbates...
...or everybody has this kind of sex with their spouse...
...or eats this kind of food or picks their nose and does whatever.
A lot of taboo won't be taboo anymore...
...and that which is truly taboo will kind of rise to the surface in a way...
...and we'll see, "Well, we all can kind of agree that we don't wanna do this".
If the species survives, we'll develop that sort of organismic capability...
...and we won't be able to be embarrassed by that stuff anymore.